gen y and gen z people who are between
10 and 41 have spent what should have
been some of their most thriving years
in a pandemic many sacrificed their
in-school experience struggled to find
work lost jobs held off on big decisions
and dealt with travel restrictions i'll
be like graduating in the next like year
or so and so i think finding a job it's
very very undetermined i'm hoping that
things will stabilize but it's hard to
predict right now being a student living
at home you know rent free i do have a
job i'm hopeful that i will be one day
able to
own or rent but not everyone can say
that with hope alleged study surveying
millennials in gen z find 66 percent
don't think canada's economic situation
will get any better this year and 62
percent believe neither will their
personal finances real estate is through
the roof inflation is is skyrocketing
the price of food is up i want to get a
job in my field but if i really need the
money at that point i'll just be getting
whatever job can really help me sustain
and then pay rent personal finance
expert rubina ahmed hux says the
pandemic has been tough on younger
generations they've been on the
sidelines watching the housing market go
up they
might have lost their job during the
pandemic so they've had to go on
emergency assistance and i would believe
that most people who graduate from
university were not you know planning on
having to go on e.i paul kershaw founder
of generation squeeze a non-profit
organization advocating for young adults
says the findings are not surprising
younger people are going to school more
to land jobs that pay less they face way
higher housing prices
and they are inheriting larger
government and environmental debts 79 of
those polled feel our environmental
situation won't improve this year up
from 75 percent in 2020. i worry as life
goes back that perhaps we might go
backwards in that realm things like
electric vehicles alternative energies
and stuff like that that right now are
too cost prohibitive i think people are
more like understanding the consequences
of what's happening kershaw says people
may feel more hopeful once they see
improvements we haven't seen our carbon
emissions you know really drop
substantially 77 percent of people
polled don't believe our political and
social situation will improve this year
either that's up from 70 percent in
2020. the protests and everything right
now are certainly not something that are
you know inspiring a lot of optimism i
would like to think that we'll be able
to get back to how we were there
definitely is a lot of division kershaw
says the pessimism gen y and z are
feeling has been long coming so this
isn't just a pandemic issue this is
years in the making the seniors in our
lives they'll have actually the
guaranteed income supplement that's
delivered already and has been for
decades through the old age security
system a younger demographic doesn't
have access to that let's replicate the
same level of systems change in order to
restore the ability for hard work to pay
off charming somani global news